challenge yourself challenge yourself
challenging yourself one success model
the best what's up believe nation that's
Evan I believe in you and this channel
is designed to be a part of your daily
success routine so today let's learn one
of the most common rules that successful
people follow challenge yourself also if
you want to know what Jordan Peterson
Gorga Paul das David Goggins and others
have to say about confidence and
excellence
check out my 254 series where every day
for the next 254 days I will send you a
morning video for free to help you build
your confidence the links to join are in
the description below if you're gonna
speak effectively you have to know way
more than you're talking about it's easy
to make a buck very hard to make a
difference everything I didn't want to
do is what got me to where I'm at today
[Music]
you were quoted in on CNBC as saying
that you'd rather be remembered for your
role in jump-starting tech companies
then your skills on the court can you
talk to them but what's that about I
think you have to challenge yourself to
evolve and to grow and I think I
couldn't think of a better message for
your athletes in particular because it's
very easy for us athletes to kind of
lose ourselves and our identity by
connecting who we are to what we do and
I think that's a very dangerous zone to
be in right so it's it's common sense to
me to be able to say okay the next stage
I'm going after with the same intensity
same attention to detail the same
curiosity so of course I'd want to be
better at that than I was in my previous
career there's a pretty high bar though
you have you have enough energy left for
that orange I guess we're gonna find out
right I mean that best thing you know
you go for it and you do all you can
you've learned as much as you can't you
continue to try to continue to improve
you continue to evolve the agency where
you are right 20 years from now you can
have to look at the mirror and say I
gave it my best shot and we did the best
we could and see where we have no we're
built for struggle as human beings you
know you're not after the bubbles of
bliss that Dostoyevsky described in in
notes from underground
we're built to contend with the world
we're built to contend with reality you
want a challenge and the best way that
you can take on a challenge because the
challenge fortifies you so you don't
want to be secure you want to be strong
and you get strong by taking on optimal
challenges and so you lay out your
destiny in the world and you take the
slings and arrows of fate and you make
yourself stronger while you're doing so
and you might fail and fortune might do
you in but it's your best bet and you
know people have also people that have
extracted unbelievable successes out of
catastrophic failures and so and I'm not
saying that in a naive way I know
perfectly well what happens to people
you know you're doing fine in life and
then you get cancer and then six months
later you're dead and all the heroism in
the world isn't going to save you at
that point
but that's not the point that's not the
point
life is bounded by mortality but that
doesn't mean that you don't get out
there
contend and you develop by contending
and you minimize the net amount of
suffering in the world and that's
something man that's something to do I
started figuring out going through buds
was that the harder some is the more it
was challenged in my mind so I had to
find different ways to stay in the fight
in the state of the fight
it got me tougher and tougher and
tougher so I'm actually happy I went
through three whole weeks I never
examined it myself as a human being you
get examined yourself in the night and I
guess the best place to examine yourself
is maybe still hell week three times so
I got to exam myself a few times so it
started there it started in hell week
and it's still going now at 43 years old
so occasionally and this is true for
everybody if you live long enough life
will come for you at some point right
like something's going to happen so
occasionally life will stress you but
when life doesn't challenge you I think
it's important to challenge yourself
because otherwise you're just living in
this optimal environment air
conditioning and you know everything
else is super easy you can get all the
information in the world at your
fingertips you never have to like if you
think about how crazy just eating is in
the modern world so previously when we
lived in tribes you you had to expend
energy to get calories at a minimum you
were foraging for berries but otherwise
you probably had like run something down
and kill it or part of a group hunt or
all kinds of other things now you can
get calories without expending any all
you have to do is just tap like ubereats
on your phone or something it'll show up
at your door and you can just sit on the
couch which is of course like a recipe
for poor health but also just it's the
game has completely changed now we've
transcended a lot of our evolutionary
programming and natural situations and
so you need to be careful about
designing that to serve you rather than
to work against you because it can very
easily nudge you in the other direction
that alert you on a performance that was
very special as was the resistance in
the fight
that was shown by Venus Williams but she
was outplayed
that's one of the heaviest defeats meted
out for Venus Williams in Grand Slam
tennis Sharapova is back to her very
very best you've won our the title so we
you've done the Grand Slams in the US
Open and all of that when you look at
now going ahead it's an Olympic gold
that you would want or as a tennis
player what more is there special yeah
and I looked at gold would be special
but did I hit the nail on the head or
not yeah you did but I I think you said
I still go into every Grand Slam and I
still you know inside of me deep down I
have to feel like I still haven't wanted
because you still have to have that
hunger when you go out on the court
because if you go out on the court and
you feel like I've done this I've done
that I do it every single day that's not
fun you have to challenge yourself and I
go out there and I you have to work just
as hard if not harder I mean the tennis
has become much more physical much more
mental than it's ever been and you have
to keep striving for being better I
personally never had a proper education
so no matter how much money I made on
the tennis court I didn't I don't want
that to stop I didn't want to my
thinking to stop when you're on the
court it's like not only is it physical
and it's your putting in so much
physical work but so much of it is
mental and that's that's the challenge
that I've had since I was a
four-year-old girl is the the mental
side of the game and and I wanted to
find challenges and other in other
different areas in business I thought
would was one of them because I've
always been interested in seeing how
things come alive and how they do and
what works and what doesn't you have to
remind yourself that it's okay to feel
the way you feel when you're going for a
difficult time it's okay to feel weak
it's okay to want to cry it's okay to
feel overwhelmed just reminding yourself
that it's okay this is my number one way
of how to find strength in difficult
times is reminding yourself that the way
you feel is okay to honor that feeling
to accept that feeling to actually be
okay with that what we see or what we
perceive to be a weakness or what we
perceive to let us down or what we
perceive is a sign of you know
instability or insecurity we've got to
remind ourselves that when things are
tough
it's okay to feel that way there's
nothing wrong with them any difficulty I
go to I look to moments in history where
people have enjoyed the same pain if not
more extreme and analyse absorb and
connect with how they got through it I
like to see what they were thinking I
like to see what they did I like to see
how they structured themselves I like to
look at how they organized I looked like
to look at who they were speaking to I
like to look at what was going through
their mind at that time because you've
got to remember that any challenge we're
facing today we've faced it before as
humanity right beyond ethnicities beyond
color race creed beyond backgrounds
beyond all walks of life as human beings
we've been through challenges before and
we've got through them and therefore
reconnecting with how that's been done
before is a beautiful way of learning
how to overcome current challenges so
you can either look at your past but
real wisdom lies in looking at the past
the people who made a difference you
look at people like Martin Luther King
you look at people like Gandhi you look
at people who made world-changing
differences not single-handedly but
influenced from a single perspective
from a single point of view and really
connecting with the powerful moments in
history I've said this quote many times
I've read it many times and this quote
actually is is unbelievable and the
quote says that they fought they buried
us they didn't know we were seeds right
it's a Mexican Bravo they thought they
borrowed us they didn't know we were
seeds and I was thinking these when you
tell yourself that story
you start thinking much more differently
right a seed is buried too it's
incredible that the seed goes through
the same process as anything else it's
put deep underground right all of this
mud is put on top of it it gets rained
on it gets snowed on all these kind of
things but it knows that it's a seed so
it knows that it can grow so there
anything's possible and it grows through
and you see even plants going to
concrete sometimes right it's
unbelievable how much power a seed has
so changing the stories we tell
ourselves we can either look a
challenging situation
as opportunities for growth as an
opportunity to learn as an opportunity
to change be the change we can look at
them and and really fool down now that
that second part is okay we can even
feel like that right but we have to
recognize it's not permanent
we've gotta accept that none of our
feelings are permanent they don't need
to be permanent it's a choice so if you
need to vent vent I was saying to
someone yesterday if you need a vent
vent if you need to run run if you need
to complain complain if you need to
share how you feel do that but recognize
that those feelings are not permanent
and it'll be amazing when we've realized
we are seeds right that is the most
powerful way of finding strengths we
make these movies just like you go away
from the people you love you know you
can bring them to you on a set but
you're spending months away from your
loved ones and friends and you're
spending like most of the hours of your
day concentrating on this you know for
months in advance of shooting and you're
spending months promoting it after it's
over so you you look at every film like
oh that's a whole year of my life you
know in some form or fashion so to have
something that you really feel like is
gonna be interesting and cool and a
challenge like there's nothing you want
more than that what do you think is the
biggest risk you've ever taken either as
an actor producer or both uh I I mean I
think just the the biggest risk was
convincing myself that I was going to
try to earn a living as a comedy person
yeah that was probably the biggest
flying leap and I you know I did all the
typical things of maxing out all my
credit cards and living pretty much hand
to mouth and trying to explain to my
parents why it was a good idea and that
was definitely the yeah the biggest
other I mean and the the beta's biggest
creative challenge I have
did was filming Casa de me Padre which
is a movie entirely in Spanish I did
that yeah I'm always kind of looking for
ways to challenge myself I try to be all
that story and then as I'm writing
create visuals or situations that I
actually don't know how to do and I try
to take my directors hat off when I'm
writing and write things that I I then
come to as a director a night I said I
have no idea how to do this I have no
idea what this will look like how to
visualize it because that's when you
know you're challenging yourself and
it's through that challenge you then put
together a great team of people and
through that challenge you find
something that you haven't done before
you find something fresh and different
and that's really the fun part of
filmmaking that in that challenge
December 10th 1940 there was a massive
explosion in West Orange New Jersey
United States of America ten buildings
in a factory owned by the legendary
inventor Thomas Edison were engulfed by
flames six to eight fire departments
rushed to the scene but could not curb
the chemical fueled inferno after having
tried all that he could as Thomas Edison
calmly stood there watching the fire
destroy his entire lives
work his 24 year old son Charles came
over and stood next to him in a
childlike voice Edison said to his son
Charlie go and get your mother and her
friends they'd never be able to see a
spectacular fire like this in their
entire life
astonished and shocked by spiders
response Charles asked Thomas Edison our
entire Factory is being burnt down to
ashes bed Thomas Edison replied in
complete compulsion
yes our Factory is being burnt down to
ashes but all the mistakes we have made
so far in the factory have also been
burnt down to ashes we will start all
over again tomorrow
that evening Thomas Edison told a New
York Times reporter although I'm 67
years old and I'm completely exhausted
from running around and trying to
control the file
tomorrow I'll start all over again
afresh and so he did the next day was a
fresh beginning for Thomas Edison and
his son Charles and trying to rebuild
what had been destroyed by the fire
often this is what life does unto us our
dreams are shattered our hopes
broken efforts baffled great people they
don't cry they try to rebuild their
dreams great people don't give up live
up to the challenges that life throws at
them great people don't go through they
grow through the difficulties that come
on their path they start all over again
with great hope with great determination
with great grit and that is why they
reach the highest peaks of success that
most people only aspire for
that is why I say no challenges no
success no challenges no success now
I've got a really special bonus clip
from Sergey Brin on how to overcome
challenges that I think you're really
gonna enjoy but before that it's time
for the three-point landing questions
time to move from just watching another
video to taking action in your life for
business and if you're feeling bold
leave your answers in the comments below
here we go question number one where do
you need to challenge yourself number
two what immediate action will you take
today and number three how will you stay
consistent on this challenge
one is on playing a service that's gonna
serve millions of people when we were at
Stanford we had you know ten thousand
people using our service or about ten
thousand searches per day I should say
and now we serve over fifty million
searches per day and that's scaling of
infrastructure that that's pretty
challenging on a more personal level I
think I'm now the president of Google
and we have about 170 people now and I
think managing managing people and being
emotionally sensitive and all the skills
you learn in terms of communication and
keeping people motivated I think you
know that's been a challenge and I've
enjoyed learning that but that's that's
an important and a hard thing to learn
if you want to know how to deal with
problems and difficulties in your life
with Google Paul - check out the video
there right next to me I think you'll
enjoy it continue to believe and I'll
see you there great people don't go
through they grow to the difficulties
that come on their part